why's of the tomb raider is just around
the corner the second part in the
trilogy we weren't supposed to know
about and we've got Marrakech and alexa
ray corriea on the couch who've been
playing is for the past week or so yeah
bout all right Riley any of you doing
the review that's Mike someone else
doing a review all right so we can get
real dig into dirty about why you guys
think about to murder and Alexa first of
all how you enjoying this you find of
the old game well yes I actually I
really like the reboot I really liked
the way that they're sort of set it up
as you are building Laura like this is
how she becomes this badass
archaeologist and I'm really liking the
game a lot I think that level design is
great how does it play in really is a
very familiar to the reboot game which
he has to entertain s13 okay so they
coming up on 30 it was early 2013 as
well I thank you so it's actually been a
while yeah the best way to compare it is
if you liked that one you're going to
like this one more because they took
everything that you would have liked
about it and they doubled down on it so
what are we talking about is it um being
able to customize the Lara with upgrades
to skill points they've like doubled the
amount of skills that she has now you
can actually choose what kind of Laura
you have as opposed to just one type of
Lara there's more weapon customization
there's more weapons in general and the
world is more open instead of linear in
the first game it was it was open and it
was not it was a linear you were going
down one way in this game they are
putting you in an area where there's
lots of different stuff to mess with or
you can do the story so there is more
choice in this case so there's kind of
like there is one path for the main
quest which you can see but there's more
like stuff around the edges that you're
sort of you can go ahead and don't
really because I had a bit it on the
first one but it was kind of only those
those individual tombs it was like two
things they were like optional tombs
they told you that and yeah very it what
you know how to get anything for them
either like this one is you get like
special skills that you can only get if
you complete certain too yeah and if you
don't do the team's you don't have to do
the tombs but you don't get the scale so
here there's a lot of incentive to like
go off and explore and find stuff so
what are those tombs like how did it
play are you on your own generally is it
cuz a lot of the like I guess but maybe
one of the criticisms that I had about
the
Oh game although it was like really good
side of the reboot was that you were
shooting a lot of people and killing
about people where his tomb raider was
always kind of a more solitary game of
exploration and killing animals oh my
god so like are those tombs dude do they
have the bombast of the main quest stuff
or is it more solitary puzzle is aman ya
their puzzles there's they're very more
puzzles and there's more puzzles there
is a lot of killing there's no way to
say that there's not I always associated
Laura with killing i mean when i played
tomb raider to or any of the ones like
back on them on the old pc like yeah or
a playstation she killed a lot of people
with guns this one is just more vivid
it's more real she's shooting in the
face she's um stabbing them in the
throat poisoning them it's more
aggressive but she killed people before
yes has not changed she's just a little
bit more it's a little bit more gruesome
but you should expect that right it's a
more visually stimulating game it's more
right more interesting so yeah the the
death scenes are more intense but
they're not as crazy as the reboot one
right cuz like that was one of those
things where people were like oh man you
can really watch this lady got killed
and [ __ ] up ways like a lingering
camera that kind of was kind of staying
there that's why they turned him down a
little bit but she still gets eaten like
a tiny yet she gets eaten there's one
where she falls on spikes and like
despite goes like up through her job she
can like it's a really really go there
but I think they've toned it down a
little bit i don't think the developers
wanted this game to be associated with
her being impaled at the gut and you
know like that i'm sure a lot of people
will remember there were two scenes in
the original reboot one where she's like
going down a flood oh my god and if you
went the wrong way it was like i did
like five times in a row not because i
wanted to see it but because about that
like quit almost for quicktime years i
have to write to my girl after my own oh
yeah there's a lot of that quicktime you
stuff no this one either they've they've
reduced it there's still stuff but i
would say it's less there's and then
there's less of those if you don't hit X
you are you see this gross shot it
doesn't happen but you will there's
still elements of her dying if you make
the wrong mistake Murph killing dudes
too how does it look that first game I
remember thinking it looked real good
had all the Tres effects stuff
still here Grice not tres effects it's
called like hair powers there's so many
different your power they have wait a
minute now yeah i would say i love to
compare it's like The Witcher cuz like
she could be 500 feet underground in a
cave with no air and her hair's like
blowing beautifully it makes no sense
but like that's the way the witcher was
too but i liked the way his hair looked
and i like the way her hair looks it's
very natural and and it's cool like
they've done a lot with it and it's not
just her hair she's just they've done
extra touches to her when she is close
to a wall she touches it when she's cold
you can see her lip quiver they've done
a lot of little things that I think make
her look genuine yeah and like if you
look really really close the developers
were telling us in the first game she
gets hit in the face with like the butt
of a gun and if you look really close to
her character model there's a scar there
alright so she has like pieces of like
like her history carri like physically
on her and seen she really feels like
she's like we're seeing the single are
for the last game we're gonna see how
these of all scars gonna have the next
games are gonna be disgusted must be
like covered in bandages a shelf one I
so what are the types of environments
that you guys experienced them how much
does a game have you played like
generally like an what type of
environments to be looking at cuz the
first game was very much the tropical
island sort of yeah and that kind of
sucked right cuz you're doing the same
thing every time this one there's all
sorts of stuff yeah you have snow and
then woods and desert deserts yeah like
they've shown them in like 30 underwater
oh there's a lot of water he can play
well she can swoosh this time around oh
cuz you're not saving the first game
nope oh really no and she can kill
people underwater which we saw a little
bit of um I was telling Alex I was
bummed because in the previous tomb
raider games like way back in the day
water always had like sharks like
barracuda messed up stuff that would
kill you there's like nothing in the
water the waters just like you know
there's no scariness in the water I know
t-rex then and this one either no not
smart I mean who knows maybe the first
Tomb Raider get the first reboot
everything was like oh this is pretty
cool and then all of a sudden was like
aliens and you know you're like all
right now it's now it's [ __ ] weird
but like in this one we don't know yet
but currently it's very grounded it's
not as its subtle I mean the first one
went places too yeah the first game
yeah it's a real [ __ ] strange yeah
like spooky ghost stuff for a while at
some point they're just like you know
what let's color in space I just didn't
think it couldn't even care Lara X Jason
Commission then let's talk a little bit
about there's some microtransactions
stuff in here as well what does not take
the form of yeah people are already
angry and I think a lot of that is they
they were you hear that word and there's
aggression yeah yeah it's okay to enroll
not surprising yeah um that's not so the
micro transaction is here I think we're
actually looking at them yes i did some
screencap of it this just to show you
guys what it looks like yeah this is you
earn so you earn credits by completing
challenges you earn these Indian credits
and you spend them on card packs and the
card packs unlock weapons and gear to be
used only in the expedition road of the
game what's expedition mode it's not
it's it's not like multiplayer it's a
challenge mode that you complete
yourself but you're competing like with
other people for like high scores or you
can set up or you can go to a previous
area and set yourself a condition like
I'm gonna get through here in two
minutes or whatever and you just sort of
race yourself sort of like isolated
zones yeah yeah off of the main game
that's right so you cannot spend any
human money that in any way will impact
the story yeah you can spend human money
to get maybe increase your chance of
getting on the top of a friend's
leaderboard yeah it's all about that but
there's nowhere in the game where you
can like by money and then go in and be
like oh I want like this item like like
there's no that's just not there its
weight I'd love to know who buys this
stuff there's like so I'm smells like
like cards as I okay you know like I get
get like ultimate team I get what people
might get into that because they spent
so much time with it but like why would
you buy together you know to boost
yourself in a multiplayer thing that
just seems like I don't know if they
somebody's doing alright they wouldn't
do it if people didn't pay for it and I
understand that if people don't like it
not to give the money in the micro
transaction yeah but I think the
important distinction to make is that it
doesn't impact the actual mega game I'm
a dream so in terms of like not wanting
to support micro transactions you cannot
support them and just play so still
enjoy this game it's just a shame that i
guess like the
the fairness of that leaderboard seems
to be skewed a little bit and I think
that that's why yeah possible that these
leaderboards will go the way of Tomb
Raider multiplayer hey nobody cared
right I kind of just was this extension
and it's gone totally forgot uh well who
knows how much people will care yeah so
is there any multiplayer part from that
stuff that I else none there are there's
no like death match or anything like
that nobody cares yeah a multiplayer is
that score that pops up when you enter
an area like it'll show how your other
friends and that's the thing that we're
talking about that's like replaying um a
tomb for speed or something like that
and getting a cooler out of it and
seeing if you're the best at it
excellent last point I guess on this is
obviously this is an xbox one exclusive
game fri year for one year which guy you
know which is kind of synonymous I guess
material because it was a PlayStation
exclusive game for a number of years in
the late 90s there's no none like n64
and saturated guess there's never any
tomb raider games for the first three or
four and but it is like we're still not
used to exclusive game is like in 2015
the so few of them especially third
party ones and do you think that it's
beneficial or detrimental to tomb raider
that it's an exclusive game considering
especially the sales at the xbox one I
guess yeah it's really interesting cuz
like all the other exclusives that we
see are like from like first party
Studios like until dawn I'm there's a
game until dawn it everybody gonna the
rapture blood-borne stuff like that tomb
raider is a sequel to a game that came
out on both platforms yeah so in a way
like i can understand why players see
this as a big like players on ps4 see
this is like a nephew we're getting this
first um but at the same time like I
think that the exclusivity deal has made
that game look really pretty I think
that sort of a reason why do you think
there's like a technical benefits only
working with one I think that there's I
mean I think yeah there's a business
back ends that you're not seeing right
that there's no doubt obviously that
Microsoft it was looking for exclusives
to help with the xbox and tomb Raider's
a great one it's popularly you like it
it's a well-known franchise what a great
place for a timed exclusive will give
you some money
well crystal dynamics has probably paid
for Tomb Raider three before they've
been released I mean who knows I don't
know the exact or the days of it they've
it's benefited them because they've had
an increased development i'm a little
Veronica now they get this ability to
relax and make the game of their dreams
and I don't know as long as I said
before Christmas seriously well sopc is
scheduled for early 2016 okay and PS 4
days holiday whatever that means could
be I mean that Wednesday we don't know
which holiday yes st. Patrick's Day yeah
that's open to interpretation but it's a
time to says if it's not full and you're
giving that studio the time and the
resources that they need to be able to
maybe make the game better there's no
denying from what I've seen so far it's
a stunning game and it looks great I I
do worry that that now tomb raider has
been harmed that the public is angry and
I see it all the time people are angry
yeah at tomb raider games but that's not
really fair and i think that that's up
to the public to kind of let that go and
realize a good game is a good game
nobody i don't know i don't know how
many xboxs people who looked at
blood-borne said what a [ __ ] game like
it was like you know you call it what it
is like it might it might be it might be
bad but it's not because it was yeah a
conscious not like inherent clan is and
we're owning one console right is that
like if you did only on the PlayStation
4 and you spent like four hundred
dollars on it and then this game that
you played the original one isn't coming
out because crystal dynamics wanted a
bit more cash to maybe make the game of
your dreams or maybe just to you know
give themselves a buffer like you got on
understand why people are a bit irked
about it as well yeah yeah yeah
definitely i'm like a way he's gonna be
Amina yeah I can see it from their
perspective as well like I bought a
PlayStation 4 and I've been you know I'm
a sony fangirl i buy everything every
multi-platform game cuz on the
PlayStation 4 and then when the analysis
for Xbox it was like oh I guess like I'm
have to wait to play it then I moved in
with someone who owns an xbox right it
doesn't relax what you do yeah that's
the solution that's the San Francisco
ways if you don't have it you find a
roommate that has a boyfriend that you
never move out I don't know yeah I would
never hurt my feelings but I think I've
had an xbox since the beginning um and
you know what we really needed
no one that's fine and it's I just don't
think it falls a long way away oh god I
forgot that game existed as you
mentioned it just now I was interesting
that was a long time I got a long time
so great news for Xbox one owners great
news for pc owners in 2016 right
PlayStation foreigners and it's maybe
you look better now that in a year's
time an extra pause it gives you time to
really figure out if you want it yeah I
even come out on sale who knows but then
you have to avoid the internet for a
year for spoilers that's the problem
tomato spotted well they're sorrel on
they're still under embargo ghost an
alien so we can aliens probably go
standing I'm gonna feel bad oh god
imagine spoiler Madonna apologies future
internet okay especially those of you
watching this on the PlayStation we
don't know wanting to see if you're
gonna buy me just go in 12 weeks 5 and
let us know what you think about tomb
raider are you looking forward to do you
think the exclusivity is a positive or
negative and when you're leaving your
comment let us know which console your
own as well so you can take that into
account